hello everyone and welcome to another
Bitcoin protocol explained video in the
previous videos we covered the basics up
basic ideas behind Bitcoin in the
abstract we covered the introduction and
we cover the transactions section in
this video we're going to cover the
timestamps server the problem with
transactions is we we have a way to do
them but we have no way as of yet to
confirm that that the transaction itself
was not double spent nor the previous
transactions in this chain of
transactions we can confirm that the
person owns or at least owned you know
this Bitcoin but we have no idea if they
went to multiple parties and spent that
coin multiple times so here's the
beginning of that solution and that is a
timestamp server so let's go ahead and
hit this short section the solution we
propose begins with a timestamp server a
timestamp server works by taking a hash
of a block of items to be time-stamped
and widely publishing the hash such as
in a newspaper or a Usenet post the
timestamp proves that the data must have
existed at the time obviously in order
to get into the hash each timestamp
includes the previous timestamp in its
hash forming a chain with each
additional timestamp reinforcing the
ones before it so this should be you
know pretty familiar to you after going
through the abstract video the idea here
is that we can timestamp transactions
each time we do it or do a transaction
right and it basically is going to
enforce the previous stance right
because it's like more agreement on the
previous stamp so if you think about
like any transfer you've done in Bitcoin
you've probably seen that it takes
something like three confirmations to be
validated so this means that your
transfer has been agreed on the another
block is made and then another block is
made and so on depending on how many
confirmations are required and by this
point you've solidified your transaction
in the Bitcoin blockchain and it's also
you know widely agreed-upon the problem
is however what if someone decides to
take the chain
and just edit the chain real quick and
pass it along
then what so sadly as we've resolved one
problem we've presented ourselves with
another luckily there is a solution and
you probably already know that solution
if you've paid attention or watched the
abstract video so in the next video
we're going to be covering this notion
of proof of work we did kind of discuss
it already but we will continue it as
it's broken down further in the next
section
as always hopefully everybody is
following along well if you're confused
or have any questions or comments feel
free to make them make them below
otherwise stay tuned for the next video
thanks for watching and thanks for all
the subscriptions